I'm not built for to be famous I don't
like it you can keep it I really have
not gotten any benefit from it other
than like you know I've gotten out some
speeding tickets and some restaurant
reservations and I don't wait in line at
Disneyland and I have no judgment around
this a lot of performers kind of
inherently because nobody wants to play
to an empty house right they want to
have that attention so attention people
often conflate it with narcissism and
solipsism and self-absorption it's not
really what it is is I'm somebody who
wants to express something to people
very profoundly all people there to
respond to that and so celebrity itself
the the attention in of itself is not
valuable to me personally at all I'm shy
I don't want to tell people things I've
been criticized so often in my life and
mischaracterized and misquoted and
characterized in a way that makes me
feel uncomfortable and maybe sometimes
it was fair and I just didn't want to
accept it and sometimes it wasn't fair
and the truth is even when they write
something good I just think like I don't
want to talk about this you know like I
am not even love being here so what I'd
like to be able to do is my job and not
have to do that celebrity part